is sleeping around different for men and
for women how many men is too many men
that's none of your business it wasn't
for you and the minute a woman does it's
like oh you're a slag
and it's like easy for a woman to get
sex where guys they have to earn it five
percent of men get matches really on
tinder if it's an average looking guy do
you think he would have as much success
to a guy that's way more good looking we
were women an average looking girl and
an average girl would have a better
chance with any type of guy she would
want i've had nba players slide him
ideas
what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] away from me
what's your body count mine's warm 15.
this i'm saving myself my husband okay
call me you are you virgin let's just
say it's on the 20. you don't get
jealous a lie so would you be cool with
like multiple husbands and multiple
wives in this is that how you want to do
it yeah men don't have to face the
consequences
they always ask me to rate them and they
don't want me to do it